all right guys thank you for your
patience I'm back from the Star Trek
convention so now let's review the movie
that nobody's asking me to review and
nobody's going out there to watch The
Dark Tower
so the Dark Tower is a movie based on a
Stephen King novel stars Idris Elba as
the gunslinger very long condensed for
the movie story short this kid from our
world of having these dreams his parents
think he's kind of crazy but he's having
these dreams about this tower this man
in black in his gunslinger he then finds
a portal to that world he goes over
there he meets the gunslinger and
together they're like we need to stop
the man in black play by Matthew
McConaughey who's named Walter there's
only one menacing Walter in the history
of Walters and that is Walter that the
Dark Tower falls all of our worlds are
toast but usually I start out with what
I liked about this movie and though this
movie is not a complete buzz fire fairly
even a coherent movie interest Elva does
his part for what he has the best part
in the entire movies when he's in this
hospital and the doctors like you have
this this business you have hepatitis A
through Z it was the only real
fish-out-of-water scenario for him I
really liked it you could tell he just
didn't really understand our world which
is a contradiction to the moments in the
movie where he does understand the world
when you go from not knowing what
coca-cola is not knowing how to take
antibiotics I have to assume you don't
know what a propane cannon is so he
picked up a propane can throws it shoots
it and blows it up conflicting messages
we're really Matthew McConaughey I feel
like you just strolled up on set he's
like I'm the Shogun black talk like this
talk like Matthew McConaughey and I
guess Tash is going to be evil enough
it's really what he did it's like all he
did his character is pretty much
kilgrave from Jessica Jones he walks by
people tell them stop breathing they'll
stop breathing and die so one person
look good they're gasping that was how
it should be another guy who goes stop
breathing and this dude just goes to
comes along he's dead well that was
really fast does that guy breathe like
have to because if I stop for a second I
instantly die it was weird
didn't they go from the gunslinger world
to our world back to the gunslinger
world it really just feels like a sloppy
mess feels like he took a really sick
Stephen King book and crushed it into an
hour and a half long movie not only that
yeah there's more I heard they took
elements from other Dark Tower books
like not just the gunslinger they take
elements from the next one the one after
that maybe I don't even know if that is
true but it does feel like that
it moved felt like it was supposed to be
a trilogy and they just crushed it in
the one imagine Lord of the Rings where
they get out of the Shire go right to
Rohan
and then right to Mina's Terrace to do
the battle of the pelennor fields and
Frodo goes right over there and drops
the ring in the volcano in an hour and a
half yeah I didn't lose it a lot doesn't
but the movie does set up for a sequel
and completely cuts off before you know
you're going to get that we're not going
to get a label they want to do a TV show
that wraps into this maybe they can do
the story on a TV budget guys in the end
I was really looking forward to the Dark
Tower with a cool premise and thought it
could be a cool movie but in the end it
was a sloppy mess
I was bored I was glad the movie was
only 90 minutes long I didn't hate it I
just nothing did I will say I'm not
going to remember the Dark Tower in
t-minus one day yeah already forgot
still is implored to it though because
that's completely different starting but
not ending with the fact that it is
about an hour longer than Dark Tower
alright guys so Dark Tower have you seen
it what did you think about it though
you did or what your favorite Stephen
King book to movie adaptation whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]